Having to learn about something so
abstract and complicated as the cell,
being the smallest unit of
life, you know, I sorta wanted
to make it larger than life.
So we literally went big.
We went really, really big in
creating this giant cell model,
just to obviously give them
an experience to remember.
My name is Rob Olazagasti,
sixth grade science teacher,
School of the Future.
>>How do you think the
lysosomes digests like--
destroys bad bacteria, basically?
>>A big part of this project
was having them act as a teacher
and I wanted them to have a setting
in which they could teach from.
So, you know, we created this giant,
plastic cube, which we modeled
after a cell, with their different
cell organo models in there.
And it's something that they
definitely never forget.
>>Anybody else?
>>It's awesome to have my
class inside the giant cell,
because it's a better
understanding of the cell.
Like it's actually an experiment.
Like we get to be there.
We don't just write
and read about it.
We get to experience
that life giant cell.
>>The artistic sense of the way
that he approaches science is really
unique, and kids really take to that.
And Rob's definitely a great
example of somebody who's had to--
he's always had creative projects,
always had really hands on science.
>>When you create something,
you also learn.
>>The kids have been learning
about the living cell.
We started off our
studies with an analogy,
using something that's
very common to them,
something that they all obviously
understand, New York City.
Looking at how New York City
can be structured as a cell.
So they represented various
organelles as metaphor,
using different parts of the city.
So for example, they have the
subway system being representative
of the rough endoplasm reticulum.
The nucleus being City
Hall and the Mayor.
So they took the creative approach
to learning about the cell parts.
So taking the different working parts
of New York City and applying them
to a cell model allows them
to understand the structures
and the functions better.
So as that project was
sort of on its tail end,
the kids then became experts on
one specific part of the city,
or one specific part of the cell
itself and one specific organelle.
So they researched, developed
lesson plans and created models
that they were to use
to teach their students
about the organelles
that they had created.
They were required to have sort
of a structured lesson plan
with a driving question and an
objective, some sort of task
that the students would be
doing, and then some sort
of assessment at the end.
>>And the jump start.
>>This project specifically, I tried
taking a step back from, you know,
sort of the teacher role and really
helping my students develop their own
voice as teachers.
>>I kinda like it a lot,
'cause I like to teach people
but it also feels amazing inside,
like that you have
experience to be a teacher.
>>All right, so for
the driving question,
how do lysosomes protect
the living cell?
Daina?
>>They understand what it takes
to be a teacher, and what it is
like to plan a lesson, what
it's like to execute a lesson.
But also, I think, more
importantly for them,
it builds their confidence
in the content.
Having to know what you're doing
before you teach it really makes
a difference.
So during their presentations, I was
assessing their overall presentation,
their confidence and their
comfort with presenting the lesson,
and then the content itself, how
well they were hitting the facts
that they needed to hit, how well
they were expressing what we talked
about in our individual
conferences with those groups,
how well they expressed that or
presented that to their students.
Also, their creativity
and their effort.
I was sort of keeping a running
record throughout their lesson
of things that they said, things
that they did, and suggestions
on how they could improve
for the next time.
So at the end of this, I'll have sort
of a sit down with them again to talk
to them about the different elements
of their lesson, from my notes
and from my experience
with observing.
>>People love Rob and love his class.
To have such an intellectual
environment,
he doesn't baby down science words.
He uses sophisticated
vocabulary in his class.
He talks to them like scientists,
talks to them very seriously.
>>So why did I go back and disagree
that it would be in a plant cell?
>>When you can change it up,
make it your own, you know,
really make it personalized for
the kids, it comes from the heart.
It's no longer, you know,
teaching curriculum from the book.
It becomes, you know,
curriculum from the heart.